[Music]
new at six from our i-team we are
learning more about the allegations
against a former pastor at a local
church metro investigators believe there
are more victims and now our i-team's
david charns finding out dozens of his
congregants confronted him apparently
earlier this year david denise the
i-team learning 60 people including 11
alleged victims confronted this now
former pastor investigators say one by
one girls ages 15 to 23 stood up in
church and claimed sexual abuse
52-year-old femina rangel ramos was the
presiding pastor at centro cristiano
bethel for more than 20 years until
april when he resigned police writing
and arresting documents quote after the
girl spoke pastor rangel said he was
sorry said he would quit being the
pastor and he left the church you can
see here that his name has been scrubbed
from the sign outside that building the
church right near the intersection of
vegas and rancho that is just south of
texas station now investigators believe
rancho ramos inappropriately touched
teenagers and young women and they say
there could be more victims who are just
reluctant that is to come forward to
them
el ramos facing two counts of lewdness
with a minor and three counts of open or
gross lewdness with a child in
connection to what police say are
incidents between november 2019 and then
april of this year now my colleague
oracle mana tried to speak to rangel
ramos's family earlier this week but a
woman who answered the door there said
he had nothing to say she had nothing to
say today a phone number for that church
was disconnected i'm david charns 8 news
now denise